[Music]
okay this is very exciting we have a
very real doctor on the show real doctor
yes I'm real this is wild
this is crazy I feel like we have like
I'm with Google this is like Google in
person except the truth we've had a
respond but thank you for that
introduction I am such a this is
actually I never get starstruck but
because I've read your books like I'm
kind of geeking out and I'm really
worried that you're like looking at me
and seeing all the advice of yours that
I haven't taken just by looking at me so
there's some fear in me I definitely no
question about it so can you please
explain exactly what you do because I am
so afraid I'm gonna mispronounce it and
embarrass myself okay so I am at heart a
cancer doctor yeah I see patients with
cancer I have a research lab I developed
one of the new treatments of breast
cancer we developed and we developed
technology for disease I also see
patients for wellness and developed a
clinic on that and then I write books
it's obviously limited in the number of
patients I could see so I started to
write books to put ideas on paper and
then to educate I do the CBS Morning
Show I talk to people about science and
medicine several days a week and then I
lead health on a global basis through
the World Economic Forum at Davos we do
a lot there to try to again push the
agenda on health I mean my job is to
change things and I love a short guide
to a long life that book because I
didn't get more confused while I was
reading it like you put things in terms
that a dumb person like me can
understand and can actually execute
because I mean especially was what's
going on with kovat which we'll get into
in a second is that I feel like the more
I read about it the less I know about it
you know that book came about I ripped
my first book it was called the end of
illness it was about modeling health in
the body is a complex system it did very
well globally and then it was Steve Jobs
who had read it who goes EGIS he goes
you can't do this to people I go what do
you mean he goes it takes some 20 pages
to get to something you have to just
distill it down because it matter
like I don't want to have to get a
medical group degree to understand
medical advice he's like I just you put
it in terms that I can really understand
that's really digestible and we'll get
into this more but you can text dr. agus
at 3 102 9 9 9 3 2 2 when the pandemic
first started I felt like I was I mean I
had migraines I was exhausted I was sick
my eyelids started twitching from just
the amount of scrolling I was doing the
amount of stuff that I was reading and
completely you know I'm not a scientist
I'm not able to delineate what's
misleading and what's not and I remember
reading this statistic that was like
kovat has gone up 50% wherever it was
and then I read it was like well that
could have gone from 10 to 15 cases but
50% sounds so big and then I you know
and like I just feel like so many of
these headlines are about outraging us
and about misleading us and just about
getting us to click and they're so
sensational that the only because I
really trust are your text messages in
your updates at this point well thank
you I mean it really is crazy and part
of it is the media don't understand
yesterday I mean just yesterday there's
a headline that immunity only lasts two
to three months because the studies
showed that antibodies go down after two
teeth reminds what they didn't tell you
is that an immunities are from t-cell
not antibodies so while antibodies did
go down it was relevant to immunity and
they all missed that every headline
missed it either they didn't understand
it or just they kept at it long enough
right and so what would you say are the
most frustrating myths that you have
seen as a medical doctor
so far in the news or currently well I
think we see a lot know that the virus
is changing it's getting weaker it's
getting stronger tating we have
different strains in California and New
York it was in New York's fault because
they have a bad strain we had a good
strain here in California to hear that
all of these things just aren't real you
know you know we're not gonna catch it
probably from surfaces we're gonna catch
it from droplets right takes about a
thousand droplets for me to spread it to
you and every time I breathe I breathe
out about 40 droplets most of them hit
the ground from gravity I have a really
big mouth I feel like I breathe out way
more drops you're probably in the 60 or
70 but that's a different issue but so
at a dinner party with ten people one
person has it they're sitting at a table
for
ninety minutes only the person or two on
either side will get it the others won't
because social distancing works right
wearing a mask works about it everybody
in the room here is wearing a mask
we're just social distance and say but
that works by Oh simple things but we
can't normalize that behavior we're the
only country in the world that I know of
with a bill of rights we all have our
individual rights so therefore I don't
have to wear a mask right it's become so
politicized as it frustrating to see how
this has become a political issue and
about and it's sad I mean so many things
got politicized I mean over and over
again many scientists who should be
standing up at helping art because they
don't like the current administration
and they forget that our role is to help
people mm-hmm doesn't matter who the
administration is you know I worked on
Biden as his cancer initiative I work
with Obama a number of it's just a
matter of where it is we have to work
with all of them and so can I ask you a
couple things cuz I feel like I've read
some new information I tried to like
study up and seem very smart for you I
feel like I'm gonna fail miserably but
is it now true that is killed by
sunlight so UV radiation which is what
sunlight can definitely degrade the
virus it takes some time but it will
definitely degrade the virus literally
there's a handful of cases that have
been spread out of doors in the United
States almost all of them are spread
indoors where there's little ventilation
and will you have close contact with
someone over a prolonged period of time
hmm and so do you feel like at all and
that the negative physical effects of
being super worried about this fire is
impact and having false information is
also bad for our health Oh many things
about this yeah no question the stress
involved is bad for health the country
we know is not sleeping well mm-hmm I
mean there's collective data from the
fitbit's and the Apple watches of the
world that we as a country are not
sleeping well we're drinking more
alcohol we're doing less exercise we're
interacting through zum-zum is
two-dimensional you know our bodies were
made so we see each other in three
dimensions we get these cues and that's
how our brain works
it keeps searching for them unzoom and
it doesn't see them and it really hurts
our brain so this generation of kids you
know we're changing their brain over
these months and so we have to be really
concerned about that there's no question
mental health we're not paying attention
to right now
because that really scares me because I
do I feel like so much of moving forward
with this wake up call about pandemics
and possibly the future ones that are
coming down the line is our immune
system health and the panicking and the
fear and the not socializing which we
know is not good for your immune system
and also just the general fear of other
people like I go down the street and you
know you have your mask right here in
honor I mean people just like are
yelling at each other they're attacking
each other that's just like human beings
are the things we're supposed to take
comfort in and sort of get that but you
know social comfort from and now
everyone that is a stranger is your
enemy you know the first inning of this
fight against the the virus we all got
right stay at home just be confined we
understood that but this second inning
we don't understand right we don't
really know how we're supposed to behave
we don't know what are the right and the
wrong how close how this and so when you
don't understand something stress goes
up man and you don't know what's going
to happen stress goes up and we have all
of them now like I'd rather have bad
news than be uncertainty about possible
bad news like I can cope with bad news
because then I can start to adapt and
adjust but it's like it could be this or
this that's when I'm just like
perseverating and so panicked it's like
and when we have leadership you know we
just don't have it to get normative
behavior change you need leadership and
in our country now it's sorely lacking
at all levels at the mayor level the
governor level the president level
they're all saying different things none
of them really know what to do and yes
it causes stress where do you get your
news you know I'm lucky and that you
know I get to talk to you know literally
oh these calls all day with health
leaders from around the globe them so we
know what's happening mm-hmm so all
morning I was speaking with a group at
Oxford about the vaccine right looking
good by the way I also read somewhere
tell me if this is not sure if a keynote
that the only problem would be that we
might run out of glass for the vials
which I've talked about on this podcast
before that we're running out of sand
I've talked about this and no one
listened the FDA had a regulation that
vaccines have to be in certain vials and
yes there could be a shortage of vials
when you have to make three billion yeah
all we need to do though is make a
multi-dose vial so if you put 20 doses
in a vial
larger vial hmm we're gonna use them all
at once obviously that got over that
problem so that was a hypothetical issue
that that whistleblower break came up
with in January but it was a very easy
fix to that one okay do you that won't
we got but it's amazing to me it's so
cool that you have the greatest
institutions in the world Unites States
these great colleges that are changing
everything tech Silicon Valley and an
institution that survived the plague
from a thousand 46 Oxford University has
the best vaccine so it's like the
biggest fu to the whole technology world
the oldest so how is it going because I
think you know I chose a business my
friend Taylor Souter - who's a comedian
you know we chose a business where we
get a bunch of people into a building
make them sit shoulder-to-shoulder and
force them to exhale on each other for
two hours then it was a weird call and
in our business and entertainment the
big conversation is as soon as there's a
vaccine we're back is it that simple
well we have to have a vaccine and we
have people to give it to everybody the
big question is how long with a vaccine
less and how we don't know yet you may
need to get it every three months every
six months or once a year we just don't
know that yet and will take a little
while to do that but we're gonna get
better testing in the country we're
gonna get quicker testing in the country
so a lot will change over the next six
months but I really think that there is
light at the end of the tunnel the other
side of it though is that as soon as we
have a drug that we know works your
shoulders come down right right right
then it's like the flu you get sick we
give you a Tamiflu right if we have that
drug and there's some drugs that look
really really encouraging we're gonna
see about very soon and so I'm gonna
look I'm not a doctor I get to say
things like this like am I crazy that
I'm a little trepidatious about putting
this thing in my body like I bees
available I'm like I'm gonna maybe go
next week I'm gonna let you guys be from
Oxford yeah it's a vaccine that has been
around for 15 years and all we did was
took the little tip which so the spiked
protein of SARS virus and put on the
spike protein of Kovan 19 so the vaccine
is safe has been tried in thousands of
people and it was very good and so the
good is this is just a small advance on
previous I
so remember wala vaccine is a trick shoe
the immune response it hey that's
foreign let me make an immune response
and when the virus comes that spike
can't get onto your receptor in your
cells and can't get inside so the
science is beautiful it will be safe
it's already been in 7,000 people is
gonna be in a lot more before it goes to
you because everybody knows about you
and yeah we will be safe I'm confident
of that and then is there still sort of
this conversation about different blood
types reacting differently yeah I heard
that from Alex Jones and it is true so
it is true but it's a tiny bit different
okay so if you have a blood type you
have a slightly slightly high likelihood
higher likelihood of getting the virus
and I'm getting sick from the virus if
you have a blood type you have a
slightly less it's such a small
difference than it really doesn't make a
big difference in the scheme of thing
but yes it does provide for good
cocktail party company just bragging
about your blood type
I'm a plus whatever are knowing yes the
bad ones here going down I don't even
know my blood type how's that is that
seriously yeah I don't think I do know
is that which is the answer I don't
think I do it's not everything you need
to know no I mean it's this is really
making me realize that you know I need
you know we all need to take
responsibility for our health you know
and I think that I definitely have like
the fact that I don't know that is that
dark and sad no it's very common okay
and again I much rather you know other
things about your health and your blood
type right because no matter what
they're gonna test it and it's very easy
to do but you're right I mean we all
have to know ourselves
yeah and that's what's critical look do
we have risk factors you know you don't
have blood pressure issues that I know
of and you don't have diabetes you're
not obese and you're not over 65 so
you're very low risk right so how do we
tell a generation like yours change all
your behavior that could affect you but
to help somebody else
mhm new door country that's new to us
yeah I'm being told you're 37 you're not
allowed to go out and meet anyone your
eggs are rapidly rotting but you're not
allowed to go out and date right now
[Laughter]
can I ask you about the vitamin D
conversation yes because it's if you
have vitamin D helps but also doesn't
anyone who's already sick with it
already have a vitamin D so it's the
other way around is that what happens
with your body is that when you get
inflammation in your body vitamin D
Falls it was from inside the blood
vessels to the tissue so there's a paper
saying that well people with Cova 19
have lower vitamin D and they do it was
an association it wasn't causal so it
wasn't because I didn't have enough
vitamin D that I got it it's I got it
therefore I right and so therefore that
lowered the vitamin D and so taking
vitamin D doesn't help it actually did
you know decreases the sensors the
receptor for it so taking supplemental
vitamin D doesn't help and there's a
clear you know thing in nature you know
the reason we tan is to block vitamin D
right so it told us too much vitamin D
was isn't good for us yet we go when we
take these pills if you take an elderly
woman and give her vitamin D you
increase her rate of bone fracture don't
decrease it you increase it there's
never been a positive study ever with
supplemental vitamin D and when I say
that people get all upset because I've
just you know insulted their religion
mm-hmm I've insulted something they had
done for a decade they get very
aggressive right but you have to go with
the data but no the vitamin D Singh was
taken out of context mm-hmm it's like if
I walk through the streets of New York
City and I said oh my gosh everybody
with an extra large shirt is obese
therefore extra large shirts must be
causing obesity right but going on the
Sun which gives you vitamin D could
maybe kill the virus so if you're going
on the Sun for your vitamin D you might
be side two birds one is outside it
works right it makes an enormous impact
if you want to meet with a friend go in
your backyard and have dinner with them
and then it's fine
do you foresee there being some kind of
tracking situation for either antibodies
for having been tested or taking the
vaccine because I like listening Alexus
recording everything but I look forward
to touring again we'll talk about what
it looks like to go back into the world
and movie theaters and in public and
stuff but is the first time in my life
that I'm like I kind of want to know
your private data and you should I mean
and there will be and there has to be
right you have a right to say I don't
want people who are not vaccinated to
come into my club because they could
spread it to others you know there's a
portion of our population babies people
who are getting cancer therapy people L
do who are not gonna respond to a
vaccine so if you get sick and you hug
grandma you could kill grandma even if
grandma had a vaccine cos is not going
to work in certain people so this thing
called herd immunity which means enough
people are vaccinated is critical and so
we have to know who's vaccinated or not
you're gonna see clubs where you give
them your license it'll be tied to your
license they owe you vaccine come on in
and watch Whitney and say why don't you
just watch her an HBO I think it's
better or Netflix or whatever channel
you're on so is it still you can be 24
days spreading it in asymptomatic it was
16 now it's 24 not really I mean so what
happens is if this horrify you that like
I'm up-to-date on stuff and this is how
wrong I ask me most scientists don't
others most doctors don't know this and
this data's all new you never realize
this virus is new to all of us you know
I came about this right there's a thing
called the World Economic Forum in Davos
hmm and I went there and I'm
representing health and we're talking
about issues and health and as soon as I
got there some Chinese person who I had
met before ran up to me with an iPhone
and he shows me a FaceTime video of a
guy and this was a doctor in China and
ophthalmologist who was said oh my gosh
it's chaos here look at all the people
in the hallways and I go what are you
talking about this virus and he started
showing mousse we pulled together health
leaders and literally every day he was
showing us and telling us this turned
out to be the whistleblower a week later
he died of the virus himself and so this
was our exposure to it this was all new
this virus we never heard about you know
one of the greatest scientists of all
time Josh Lederberg
he won the Nobel Prize and amazing I
said in the mid 90s the only threat to
man's and women's dominance on this
earth is the virus it is our wits our
brains versus their genome and it was an
amazing prescient statement if you think
about it over a million years our genome
humans evolved 1% this virus can change
1% in a day so it's a crazy enemy that
we're all learning
this is all new and then we in our
country said hey listen all these
universities with all these great
scientists and doctors you guys go home
let's close all your labs so instead of
using our science which is our secret
sauce we sent them home and how are we
gonna fight this when we had no
scientists for the last couple of months
in this country
it's wild that's wild and so what do you
make of this like second wave first
because and I'm sure you are you trying
to self with really smart people I don't
so I get my news from comedians really
dude the second wave is coming it's not
like the things that people have decided
our true I knew the second wave joke
there's nothing funny about any of this
unfortunately but no I mean because I
think that he didn't tell me if I'm
wrong human beings need some false sense
of control some modicum something to
look forward to something to like
relieve stress something to just a lie
to tell ourselves just to get through
the day and we're like the second wave
is coming here like we just need some so
in 1918 which was the Spanish flu which
by the way started in Kansas and not
Spain that's right it was World War one
and nobody could talk about a week now
the country Spain was intense and that's
where it came from but you know it went
around the globe three times because
back then nobody flew place to place and
it was slowly passes around the globe
you know now people getting planes to go
anywhere and so we haven't gotten rid of
the first wave right a thousand people a
day are still dying in the United still
in the first wave so we're still in the
first wave so the argument is if we all
wore masks we would literally stop this
overnight and so three four weeks later
our cases you know I say we'll go down
to near zero hopefully that will happen
and that will become normalized over the
next several months and then at some
point it probably will come back but now
even now we're less stressed about it
mm-hmm the medical system knows how to
deal with it we have protocols that that
we can make most people do okay with it
not all but most we know about socialism
we know about mass we know about
behavior so we know a lot more than we
did then and we have some drugs that are
now showing just our benefit or that are
out there but there will be more of this
this is not going away till we have a
vaccine and most of the world is
vaccinated and what is that going to
look like once there's a vaccine is that
I mean just our health care system and
the way that it
which is you know constantly confounds
me like all right you know is it can be
something you pay for is gonna be
something insurance obviously covers in
me something you're you know it's like
it's gonna be like the flu shot where
it's like optional it'll it'll be a flu
shot it will have to be outfits by the
way I don't I got the flu shot like once
I don't even really get it
that crazy I know I saw in your book you
said it's not my book and me saying that
it's the data saying that fighter for
this uh saying like you know I think
this is really making me learn like as
human beings like you know all of our it
used to be like if you have money you're
gonna be in better health now everyone's
health depends on everyone's health like
we really are all in this together it's
so interesting right the way we got our
country to stop smoking the biggest
impact on smoking with the secondhand
smoke argument yeah oh you do whatever
you want but if you smoke in a
restaurant you're gonna harm everybody
else we eliminate smoking by over 60 70
percent literally overnight with that
argument it was a powerful argue I'm so
codependent I responded I would never
get a flu shot for myself but if I knew
that I could spread this to someone else
I would get the vaccine for kovin I'm
more worried about other people yeah and
that's the point is that you got to
protect others and so this is us working
together is gonna be the reason we do
measles mumps rubella all those
childhood vaccines are because there are
some kids who don't respond to vaccines
so enough kids have to be vaccinated or
we're gonna be in trouble we're seeing
outbreaks already now predominately in
California because we have this groups
of individuals who don't believe in
vaccines and it can really harm people
hmm
and so yeah we all have to step up for
each other and so unfortunately the
military is going to get involved in
administering them that they're already
training now it will be kind of mass
immunizations just like they did for
polio and others and we'll do this you
know the first vaccine it's an amazing
story right this guy Edward Jenner
notice that women who milk cows milk
maids would get pucks on their arms and
they could take care of people with
smallpox which was killing a good
portion of the world at the time and
they would never get sick so he like any
good sighs listen I went to the king of
England I wanted to put a needle in and
take pus from their arms and eject other
people with that pus
the King said you are freaking crazy the
next day that King called him up and
goes you know you have one child
five years old I know it was really hard
to have this child and you can't have
any more year older if you inject your
child on do you believe and he did
inject the child
five days later number two through
eleven who got that vaccine with the
royal family so because the royal family
did it the king was the second person to
get the vaccine
everybody in the country wanted it and
literally we were able to start to stave
off smallpox with the first vaccine and
it was an amazing demonstration of
leadership standing up for what you
believe in and standing up for your
country taking the risk for others hmm
the interest thing about vaccine is you
know to do a real vaccine trial takes
time yeah and you got to hope that a lot
of people get the virus or you're not
gonna know the vaccine where I ate
that's what we can do what's called a
challenge trial so what if we took a
hundred people we said here's a vaccine
a hundred people and then we said a
three weeks later we gave them the virus
if they didn't get sick the vaccine
worked and we would know it right away
versus serendipitously waiting three
four months and during that time we're
losing a thousand people day in this
country tens of thousand around the
world should we be doing a challenge
trial I volunteer as tribute I did there
was a point where I was like I just want
to get this thing I just want to get it
and get it over with you know and then
is it still true that if you maybe it
never was if you get antibodies you can
give them to other people
you can't give you anybody to other
people you oh you can through the
convalescent plasma I don't want them
hangs a lot in my body but the large
trouble that didn't work because the
problem is not all anybody's are good
antibodies and so we don't yet have a
test to know which are the good and the
bad yet so this mass giving was great
that people gave back but the clinical
trial didn't show that it really worked
that well is the problem and so we don't
know how long immunity lasts so if you
got it you may be susceptible again
three four months right the common cold
which is corona virus you last about
three or four months immunity and then
you can get a cold again and I was
listening to you
commend the Sacramento governor I
believe it was about the eating outside
and stuff like that how do you feel
about the way other states have opened
because it seems like a lot of spiking
but I'm looking and it's a lot of bars
and closed spaces and you know places
that are really claustrophobic no we
don't mandate wearing a mask la the
mayor said you have to wear a mask but
if you don't I won't do anything since
nobody wore bad I look at restaurants
you know I just drove by a Dan Tana's
and yeah they put all their tables in
the parking lot so it's a great old time
la yeah all right they said listen we
want our waiters and our chefs and
people here to be able to have a living
and to have a job yeah let's figure out
a way to do it it may not be as
comfortable you maybe live a cold after
wear sweater when you go but it's clever
you're gonna be fine eating outside and
it's safe and that's great right
so I love when people do that creatives
on data and do it right yeah and look
I'm I think I'm in the minority when I
say you know that Las Vegas governor
this is my opinion not David's but I I
commanded brush music we have to open up
just so that entrepreneurs can start to
think of solutions for this like they're
creative we have to start you know
thinking of solutions to the problem
what's the iteration that does work we
can't go back to the way it was that
doesn't work like how are we gonna
evolve and change our kids have to go to
school that's right they're going crazy
and I was you know talking to you know
Taylor about this and going back to do
stand-up in movie theaters and stuff
like there could be an iteration where
we're doing this outside and you know we
have partitions in between you know are
we doing every five seats or something
like that like we have to figure out
what version of this actually does work
you go with your families because you're
already sequester together yes and you
put one seat in between and you wear
masks you're gonna be fine Benten quick
question now we probably have to cut
into some actual logistic and hard
science and facts here would you buy a
t-shirt for $50 if you only knew it'd
cost seven dollars to make no you
wouldn't I'll let you answer no you
never have to overpay for quality
clothes with ever Lane did you know that
what kind of essentials do they make
that's right I'm not paying for the
billboards I'm not paying for the
frickin stores and the chairs and then
you know I'm gonna go to a store you're
in see all those fancy chairs and the
fitting rooms we're not paying for that
at every Lane okay and also by the way
I'm gonna go off-book here it's just
cute like I owe my favorite style
is like Annie Hall Katharine Hepburn
like like is she a boy or is she a girl
from far away we can't tell like that's
my style
and I love the Blazers are cute remember
when I wear the Blazer and that blue
like oxford shirt on dr. Oz's show not
me not me I don't work for anybody I
don't work for that I don't work for
those companies I'm not gonna advertise
your brand on zoom' essentials let's
talk about the essentials what if you
were to think of some adjectives to
describe these these essentials what
would they be
besides beautifully body hugging
Classique yeah alright but I am starting
to post up in my Instagram stories of me
wearing eberlein so you can see that I'm
not a big faker unless it comes to
orgasms right now you can check out our
personalized collection at ever Lane
dot-com / Whitney plus you'll get free
shipping on your first order that is a
steal that's ever lane comm / Whitney by
the way I got their Instagram I follow
them on Instagram and I there's a pair
of pink jeans that I really want but I
think so I want a pair of pink jeans
from ever Lange cuz I think it would
make me seem like I have a better
personality so get on that bentham ever
Lane comm / Whitney be cute timeless and
classy manscaped I'm not even looking at
the that manscaped
okay here's what I'll say no matter how
how smooth you think you are how much
you're shaving your balls are putting
your leg up on the tub and stretching it
out like an elephant ear and trying to
shave it with that you know nasty razor
that you like took from a hotel or how
much you think shaving your chest dude
you always have hair in your nose all of
you guys have hair in your nose and it's
just
sting and there's nothing we can say
about it and it makes me gag and not in
the good way
so manscaped I don't even know if this
is what the ad is about but they sent
this little nose trimmer and I used it
on him and I even use it on myself and
it just cuts off your little nose hairs
if you guys are just listening and not
watching this on YouTube that's your
loss because I'm currently trimming my
nose hairs oh did you hear those little
crackles the crackles means it got a
hair
you hear that got a hair yeah I wonder I
actually did it a little bit oh I just
went I just put snot on my face because
I tried to I can you can also sort of
trim your eyebrows with it I kind of did
that a little bit but yeah I have made
my lover fully bald he feels like a
marble floor and it is an absolute
delight I'd get on him and slip right
off which is which is really my dream in
the bedroom manscaped there is no excuse
to smell like chowder and be swampy and
wharf e in your scrotum these days are
over if you are a girl listening you
don't have to put up with this scalloped
scent anymore from your man it is time
to purchase manscape products for
yourself or for the men in your life
dedicated to helping you level up on
your full body grooming game ok the
perfect package 3.0 kit comes with the
essential lawnmower 3.0 you got to do
this because here's what you guys so
much and when you shave your balls and
your whatever the what's the what's that
air sternum or I think you get razor
burn and it leaves little red bumps and
it looks like you have herpes of the
chest and it's unattractive do not shave
against the grain with a cheap-ass razor
ok get the the third-generation trimmer
that is has skin safe technology to
reduce manscaping accidents right don't
give yourself an accidental nipple
piercing while you're shaving yourself
you can also adjust the settings to get
any length that you like which I really
appreciate because sometimes it's like
it's like there's no gray area with you
guys it's like completely bald or it's
like a brillo pad there is in between
lengths that we can
here crop cleanser keeps your hair skin
and healthy all in one formula because I
know you guys can't handle more than one
bottle you guys get so confused this is
like the peanut butter and jelly in one
jar of man soaps for a limited time
subscribers get two free gifts the shed
travel bag which is a $39 value of
that's cool and the patented
high-performance reduced chafing
manscaped boxer briefs
I like that do yourself a favor always
use the right tools for the job get 20%
off and free shipping with the code
Whitney 20 at manscape com that's 20%
off with Free Shipping at manscaped comm
code Whitney 20 do you think that movie
theaters comedy clubs music venues do
you think those will come back in 2020
it all depend on T 20 probably not I
don't think we're ready for it yet in
general you're not coming to see me
perform at the Oxnard improv next month
is that what you're saying I'm coming
you see perform on the lawn in the back
of that like it's just we're not we're
just not there I mean colleges are gonna
have that right in the fall they're
gonna go to school and they're gonna put
social desistance with kids they're
gonna wear masks and they're going to be
fine hmm we're gonna do testing we're
gonna get better testing on now testing
is you know we've screwed up testing
four six seven weeks and yeah yeah none
still the testing today takes a day or
two to do it costs a hundred bucks if I
test you and tell you the results two
days later it's almost meaningless
yeah days you went you you you
interacted with a million people yeah do
we need on-the-spot testing that's right
away that's cheap and easy and it's
coming I've seen it it's coming and so
that'll be a big advance because then
we'll know things yeah you can know who
you can hug you can know who can go to a
club that's a whole different story
right listen Hawaii did it right right
it just closed its borders right and if
you want to go to Hawaii you have to be
sequestered for 14 days and get a test
that makes all the sense in the world
but as testing gets easy that's not
gonna be draconian there's gonna be the
new normal and I also think that you
know from a psychological perspective
it's not about like for comedy
entertainment music not about when it
physically opens but then also when it's
conducive to joy not worrying I mean
there used to be a day where we would go
into a comedy club or a bar it'd be
pitch black
waitress would hand you a glass you
would take it and drink out of it in the
dark I mean well I mean just the idea
that right now everything is you know so
loaded and there's just such a sort of
recoiling to be around anyone you know
when do you do you think that the
ability for people to be comfortably
around each other and and going to bars
and stuff that will come after the
vaccine the same way that you know we
were able to go on planes after we sort
of took our shoes off it was just sort
of like even if it was a placebo effect
to just go like I feel safer I took my
shoes off before getting on an airplane
no question if I told you you know 15
years ago that you have take your shoes
off or go on a plane but before 9/11 you
said I'm crazy now it's commonplace in
the second nature this will be the same
we're gonna have slightly different
interactions we're gonna have vaccines
and we're gonna care about health right
I mean that's gonna be the positive this
we're gonna care about our health as a
country as a globe and other people
south like your health and my health are
now intertwines me were all one
community and we forgot that we became
independent and you know it was about
ourselves and we interact with others
and it mattered listen no offense but
you have temple more viruses in you
today that you do in human cells you
have more viral DNA and Witney than
human DNA viruses are part of us there's
just a couple that are bad actors and
we're learning that now so I'm full of
viruses as what you're saying all of us
are bacteria and viruses I mean I share
microphones with Road comics so I
believe that so
that's would you fly right now airplanes
every four minutes they recirculate the
air and they put it through a HEPA
filter so if I listen I'm not flying
because I don't have to if I had to fly
I would choose a flight that had less
than that 60 percent occupancy I look at
how many empty seats there were I would
go to the airport when it's not that
busy and I don't feel fine flying yes
and if I needed to I would and so but we
all have to look at everything every
behavior we do we can reduce the risk we
never get it to zero but you have to
figure out how risk tolerant you are and
then do the appropriate thing and it
works well it's this amazing thing that
happens in the human brain where you I
find I'm just looking at my own inner
monologue and observing that my brain
likes to go I've paid my dues
like I've been inside for three months
so I'm immune like and just sort of the
way this the pendulum swings we're like
now I'm just gonna like you know I think
that so many people feel this like
slingshot effect of like I'm done being
inside right and we don't understand
what's going on now right we're not
seeing you know people around us
suffering immediately and so we say hey
listen everything looks okay
remember the dastardly thing about this
virus is about 60% of people are
asymptomatic and they could spread the
virus that's what's a crusher that's how
it's different than almost every other
virus who's seen when you get the flu
you look sick you feel sad straight it's
obvious to everyone you're dripping your
you know but so now is it now still
dripping you're dripping do you know
what I mean you're just like like yes
you know just coming out yeah like your
stuff or your gross is it still 16 days
or is it now 24 days so what what
happens is if I expose it to you you
know you will you can get symptomatic
anywhere from kind of two to three days
after exposure up to about 14 15 days
you normally are infectious two to three
days before you're symptomatic if you
are symptomatic we call that
pre-symptomatic being contagious hmm the
period of being in contagious if you're
an asymptomatic is again normally two to
three days but it could be anywhere in
that window and that's why it's really
difficult so that's why we need better
tests listen if I told you hey listen
your infectious today stay home for a
couple days you'd be fine yeah do it and
it wouldn't be an issue but the problem
is nobody knows now right and they don't
mean it but they were out and they had
some dinner with some friends and they
get a hug grandma the next day right
they can kill grandma I think that's the
other thing you know I think that's you
know fascinating right now we're not a
culture that's been particularly
respectful of our elders for the you
know longest time it's been it's been
actually kind of heartening you know at
least you know when this first started
that to watch people go okay we're all
making this sacrifice because of you
know grandma and older people older
people people with medical conditions
and then it randomly hits certain people
we don't know why I have a patient now
he's 40 years old healthy runner and
he's on a ventilator no rhyme or reason
he just is and we all have that fear
that could be us hmm
then I remember after 9/11 I was afraid
to walk the dog I was literally afraid
to go out of my neighborhood and walk
the dog that was an irrational fear
right right right right right and it's
interesting because people keep you know
when they compare
eleven and this it's interesting so I
felt like after 9/11 happened there was
this a lot of the way we healed was
getting together and going out to bars
till 2:00 in the morning and like going
you know and socializing and that's
something that we can't really do here
no we zoom we zoom we drink which is by
the way I now feel like the fact that
we're on our computers all day like is
that gonna create a whole other no
questions AGGA no question about and you
recommend the blue light glasses always
right I think I'm here somewhere they're
certainly helpful you can filter the
blue light out you know because your
body thinks it's sunlight so the problem
is you look at your when you're on your
phone or your better yeah cuz oh my gosh
it's daytime I don't want you to go to
deep sleep it was just sunny out and so
you wear those glasses it can certainly
help you especially at extreme times of
going to bed afterwards my I literally
this eye twitches since the pandemic
started is that I'm not winking at you
just FYI I am NOT flirting that's just
is that just a side effect of stress
yeah I mean your stress your adrenaline
is up your cortisol is up you need to
relax are you exercising yes we're
biking good yes you're getting out of
doors yes I'm getting out of doors on a
stationary but quite a bit no good I
don't like stationary bikes no I just
want you to be outside right so I want
you to see nature and so let me ask you
there are so many of my friends that
have kids that are like you know I can't
imagine being five ten years old and not
being able to play with friends like to
not be able to like you know hug friends
not be able to you know really hard it
just like breaks my heart the idea of
hearing about kids going to school and
it's don't get near Timmy like Sally and
Timmy you're not allowed near each other
they're not late and I think of the
elderly you know in their home and think
of what somebody gets sick I mean the
problem with this is if you got sick I
couldn't come and visit you why can't
cuz I'm a doctor but right if your
spouse couldn't come and your mother got
sick your father couldn't go and be with
her yeah so we have so many patients who
were dying alone and you know with every
disease now they're in the hospital and
they're alone right right that's just
it's in solitude just bad for our brain
and for everything right it's bad for
the person who's you know knows their
loved one is suffering and they can't be
there with them bad for the person
suffering yeah it's really hard and even
if you don't have kovat and you are
younger I was reading somewhere that
being alone we you produce less
serotonin
because your brain like subconsciously
thinks you've been like exiled from the
tribe or don't have protection from a
trial and it's putting you in danger
so you're basically in this danger mode
right right when you we were alone
throughout history we were in danger
right we were on the trail trying to
hunt right gather so that's when we were
alone we were with community we were
safe so our stress hormones go down and
we lose that sense of community now many
of us who are living alone know the 20
year old they live alone right that's
tough what happens when you see these
like you know parties and you know
people filing out of like Nashville bars
like what happens to your brain when you
see it had its listen it's really hard
for me to see that yeah when I see the
protests that are all good intent yeah
they could have worn masks and it would
have been perfect and yet they didn't
and they could harm people I mean that's
what really gets me mm-hmm is this mask
you know in Japan when you were sick you
wore a mask yeah you knew out of respect
you don't want to spread it to others
right so when they said everyone has to
wear a mask that was fine they didn't
fight back but this is new to our
country we're not used to that little
piece of cloth and you know people view
it as a civil rights issue
mm-hmm listen if I tell you you have to
wear clothes in public you do I know you
have to wear a mask you don't right if I
tell you you can't smoke somewhere you
go okay I can't smoke in the lobby of a
building yet if I told you you have to
wear a mask you say it's my right not to
hmm there was a comedy club recently
that had an act in Nashville he got on
stage collapsed on stage class collapsed
on stage it was all the internet deal
Hughley do you think that that if
everyone was wearing masks it would be
different should people be going to
comedy clubs in masks 100% or just not
going at all well you know if you go in
masks where it's not too crowded yeah oh
yeah and so we just have to normalize
that behavior problem is you know
there's an amazing psychologist Daniel
Kahneman goes if one person is walking a
street not wearing and everybody says
well he doesn't get to why do I yeah and
the next day it's five people the next
day it's brights it has to be everybody
is the problem and you know what's
interesting it used to be just the way
we're having to reprogram our brains it
used to be if you were somewhere you're
going you saw someone in a mask you'll
that person's sick now you see someone
in a mask you know go this but that
person's good and someone who's not
wearing a mask is all of a sudden Avilla
like it used to be wearing a mask meant
you were like a criminal or you were
like sketchy and shady in some way you
know we're gonna band and I'm used to
mean you were like a bandit you were an
outlaw no it's like I love that guy yeah
I mean listen going from bank robbers to
heroes I mean and they really are we
have to think about each other and it's
really hard to normalize that listen I
saw 30 patients today right my patients
were masks I wear masks isn't totally
safe my entire building I have 250
people in my building they're all
wearing man mm-hmm so it's a safe
environment right and it's also I think
that just like the signal you're sending
the same way you walk down the street
and you see someone and you know of
Raiders jurors you look at man like
we're all of a sudden connected in a way
that you know even though we don't know
each other like it's I think when you
see someone in a you know mask you're
like okay I don't have to think about
you or worry about you like I know the
way you do everything is probably the
way you do anything is probably also
watching your you you for the social
community when you hurt your knee or an
ace bandage on it doesn't help your knee
heal yeah you don't stretch that knee
right and that's the same thing with
wearing a mask
we hate differently and here's my thing
about I don't want to wear a mask but I
do want to go back to work like whatever
needs to happen to you know make this
happen sooner and my question is also
about like when we go back into public
spaces concerts you know comedy clubs
movie theaters will there be a new way
that things have will you go in and will
there be a hand-washing station well
there be temperature checks well there
you know is that going to start to be it
normal in Washington temperatures I
probably don't spread stop that much
spread of the virus the more
psychological making people aware of it
rights but yeah it's probably gonna be a
redesign of places ventilation right the
ventilation in the room Wow Wow so I was
talking to one of the best universities
in the country yesterday I said listen
you're planning to go back have you
acetate all of your room Center which is
better ventilation and not like no I'm
like why wouldn't you hmm
right if you have good ventilation it's
like being outside the virus isn't gonna
be there very long and they're not gonna
be a major issue right if it's stagnant
air you've probably been in some of
those clubs where it smells you know the
beer from yesterday yes that's a major
issue so ventilation buildings are gonna
have to redesign schools are gonna have
to redesign for that it's gonna be a new
way of doing things where we focus on
health which is good in the long run why
do people think glut why are people in
gloves you know that
like do do you wipe down your take out
or do you wipe down your shirt like are
you no we're not crazy like you don't
have to worry about that anymore right
very little viruses has never been
spread through surfaces yeah
and so takeout is fine you know listen
we go and I pop my trunk they put it in
and drive at home but we take it out we
put it on plates and we eat we support
local businesses it's great we're not
crazy you know little I have this call
with Howard Stern every couple days I'm
not as paranoid as Howard is right now I
love you Howard let's be honest I love
the fact he's talking about ya and open
about it yeah that brings it that
discourse brings understanding on things
right which i think is great right but
know you're not gonna get it for most
surfaces you I'm gonna get it from a bag
taking from somebody right oh yeah
Howard is in a hazmat suit just to go so
the medications that are currently those
aren't it's like that's not out yet the
ones that are all work right so steroids
I mean the method to zone I have
dexamethasone very good zone that's
decadron it's just the steroids we took
for poison ivy
right so that blocks inflammation of you
know most people go on a ventilator it's
not the virus causing a problem it's
your immune response goes into overdrive
and blocks that and it improves survival
and it improves you know dramatically
shortens hospitalization and then
there's a drug called REM disappear
which also works
so those are two drugs they're not home
runs yeah I work but there are a couple
in development I do have chloroquine
nine downstairs
I mean hydroxychloroquine but get the
same yeah same death if you want if you
need to clean an aquarium let me know
I'll on it give it to you and then and
so is the six feets thing still it's not
a magic okay okay I just gotta humans
need some even if it's not absolutely
true we need good orderly direction yes
we need leaders yes what to do we need a
number how many feet just tell me a
number and I'll set a notion of our
country saying every state make your own
rules makes no sense it's implying that
every one of the commissioners stated
smarter knows yeah doing which they
don't right we had the CDC for a reason
and now we're
listening and it's kind of crazy in
countries where they have great leaders
which by the way they seem to have to be
all female leaders right right once you
said it
I didn't say New Zealand come through
healing Germany I mean these are amazing
leaders yeah know what they're doing it
are tough and take no shit and I love
that I also am NOT speaking obviously as
a scientist or a doctor right now but I
know that when something changes too
many times I start to lose trust in
someone I'm not saying that's rational
but I feel like it's been you know so
every day is a new thing I'm like how
come you guys don't know this but it's a
new thing and nobody knows listen we
lost trust in the CDC the Apple health
organization we lost trust and they kept
saying things that were incorrect mm-hmm
and yeah we've lost trust and to get
that behavior change we need real
leaders and we don't have them now
health and food or 30 percent of the US
economy yet nobody knows who the Surgeon
General is nobody knows who health
leaders are that's a problem yeah I mean
wow she's kind of making them
celebrities now I mean it's sort of like
the idea of making medical leaders
celebrities you know I think is a very
cool
ouchies great we had a real scientist
yeah but we need a lot more and why when
I know there were a couple other TED
Talks I got into a wormhole around in
like 2014 2016 I think 2014 Bill Gates
called this why didn't we care why do we
listen listen
Bill Gates said yes there's gonna be a
pandemic and what is Bill Gates his
number-one investment
he owns the Four Seasons Hotels so if
you really thought there would be for a
pandemic would he have bought the Four
Seasons Hotel after that probably not so
that's the problem is a lot of people
had a lot of talk you know Bill put
together a thing in Davos a couple years
ago where they basically play acted a
pandemic and we were all in a room a
hundred of who's who in health and
everything that's happening today
happened in that room and yet we did
nothing about it so there's a lot of
people talking doom and gloom but very
few acting on it very few doing things
listen
ouchy himself canceled our coronavirus
vaccine programs so we had no
coronavirus research programs I had it
all for HIV only an HIV vaccine only
yeah nothing else so there's a lot of
talk but little action right it's very
hard for a government to spend money on
something that may or may not happen and
we were preparing for nuclear wars if
you're a president you put it on social
programs because you
to return right away you don't put it on
health things that may or may not happen
his ibuprofen still bad was never been I
need to stop getting my news from reddit
literally one of the heads of World
Health Organization we may have made
that announcement ah yeah what are you
doing there is no data that's real well
we just heard this I go check it and the
next day they actually rescinded it no
it was never real it was never real this
is a nightmare and where are we on phone
what did you lose by not taking I really
hurt your life that was my rock bottom
no it's just like it's so frustrating
when you know I think that you know
people like us like we we rely on the
smart people to tell us what to do you
know my mom's in a nursing home like I'm
doing the best I can to try to
understand and it's just like it's so
hard to do the right thing when you
can't even get the right information and
most people don't have all day to be
researching this this is this is the
most this is someone who's been
researching this all day every day for
three months and I still don't know the
answer listen the reason I give everyone
my cell phone to text that's right to
get real information that's right there
because you have to yes because and this
is again like three one oh two nine nine
nine three two two you guys know I do
this too I text back a lot you he might
not have the kind of time I have to text
Maggie every single one we takes back to
that's incredible because we have to can
we start doing and a video of you
answering some of them sometimes too or
can you post on social media your
responses so that it goes to more people
yeah I mean the problem is social media
use get attacked yes and I've had I
don't know what you're talking about
that's never happened to me I've had
death threats over the last several of
them and it gets very scary so when you
put things out there and you know it's
your beauty of this text service is yeah
people are nice that's right that's
right it's using to do it and I've never
had anybody be mean or aggressive on it
on social media people just get mean and
nasty and aggressive and really
inhibited a lot of people from saying
things right becoming the leaders they
need to be in this it scared the hell
out of them right right I mean we're
comics we're used to getting heckled and
you know I also think you know you're
the health expert but the kind of person
who's going out of their way to
Haeckel or disparage or whatever someone
is not is bless their heart like they're
in a lot of pain as my therapist would
say there's no question about it but
when they start to threaten your life
your family's ever get scared you also
can do auto block of comments I'll help
you with that so you can like pictures
but you can get specific words and it'll
just automatically block the comments
based on what you're getting the most
they caught one of the guys Iowans for
white America you would think listen I
would didn't know they didn't like me
but apparently I'm not big with Iowans
for white America oh just trying to keep
everybody healthy was very upsetting to
them it's my guess yeah you know in this
text services it's it's not only that
but you can also send out messages based
on an age group so you can send messages
to just people in their twenties just
people in their 60s based on you know
different things that matters we all
talk differently we think that's right
differently that's right and to
different parts of the country so if
Florida's peaking with kovat it seems
like it sort of is right now you can
just send messages to just Florida you
can just send messages to New York you
know and like target the information
that you're sending can I sue a couple
more dumb questions I'm never gonna let
you leave hand sanitizer
am i the only person that sort of can't
imagine constantly dousing ourselves in
alcohol is a good thing listen it's
probably not a good thing yeah honestly
that being said listen when I go into a
patient's room mhm I washed my hands
with a hand sanitizer at first I just
don't want to now it's so you'll just do
the okay do the hands out of listen just
soap is just as good okay I get me wrong
yeah there's very little virus that's
like I think I'm drunk off of Purell
it's just going into my bloodstream
drinking your blood common question you
get about co-ed I get all kinds of crazy
ones but I mean most common is just
certain behavior asking me an email
about I want to go visit grandma can I
my son just came home what do I do and
how do I so it's all these personal
behavior issues that's the key ones we
get and then we get all the crazy ones
yeah get some wild ones and I also think
that like having this conversation
everyone's talked about Kovac Kovac okay
but it's also we can have this
conversation without talking about your
immune system health in your health
anyway so I was reading somewhere that
if you're not getting a certain amount
of sleep
healthy sleep a lot of these
conversations are null and void anyway
if you're not taking care of is no
question system the doctors in Italy had
some of the worst outcomes because they
weren't sleeping and so uh ah so you had
these young doctors who you know ended
up dying many of them because of that
so yeah you need sleep you need to to
care yourself so what that means is
meals the same time every day the
tendency is snacking this is by the way
like a revolutionary think the idea of
you saying yeah sleeping and eating it's
not me saying it's the data
sorry it's sorry it's hard numbers and
science and facts yes it's the true
facts and no but I've never thought
about that before cuz I used to be the
person that was like oh I'll just sleep
in this weekend and catch up on sleep
and I'm gonna eat really healthy at
different times everyday you say eat the
same time every day and sleep me saying
oh sorry that it numbers so the data
show is that you know three meals a day
with nothing in between so if you eat
food whatever you want same amount of
calories you're gonna gain more weight
you're gonna lose about 1618 percent of
cognitive function and you're gonna lose
athletic performance just by eating at
random times you know your body likes to
know what's to expect when it doesn't
know when you're going to eat it
basically keeps your stress hormones up
expecting you to eat all the time right
so one snack in between lunch and dinner
will throw you off four to three days on
metabolism basis and on a stress basis
600 parents I said have your kids go to
bed whenever they want here's a
stopwatch wake them up nine hours later
the other 600 parents I said have your
kids could have been the same time every
night wake up in nine hours it's the
same amount of sleep in both arm almost
an eighteen percent improvement in
cognitive function and kids who went to
bed the same time and got up at the same
time that's good too great right there
yeah which 200 kids is much more true in
you and I and it's not about how much
you're sleeping it's your quality of
sleep yes if you sleep six hours a night
you're gonna have a higher percentage of
REM sleep you sleep ten hours you have a
lowers percentage so as long as it's
regular your body will get used to it
that's what's key how do you know if
you're having REM sleep is it because
you have dreams or nightmares that can
be one way if you remember more you
could just you know I have a pad that
goes under my mattress that measures my
sleep I'm about those geeks you argue
and I have a pad like it's like that
that goes under my mattress and it tells
me you know and I look at my sleep I
realize if I have two glasses of wine I
don't
sleep is deeply you know cuz wine makes
you fall asleep and then there's a
rebound surgeon adrenaline that's why
you drink your wine at noon that's
perfect yes I am one of those geeks yeah
you want to hit the geekiest things
yesterday forefathers I want to know
everything in here my son bought me on
eBay for $10 a picture of a lung from
the Spanish flu of an autopsy of a lung
as a gift for Father's Day are we not
the geekiest fan we're all science in a
myth the lung was like in Spanish I mean
it's remarkable but yes we does it look
like it does it look a little bit like
what Kova does to lungs pneumonia
exactly the same is that instead of
there being open holes where there's air
it's filled with fluid so what this
virus does is it makes your lungs leaky
fluid fills in and you can't get oxygen
in which is why you have to go in on
handle later because they put pressure
to get oxygen in and hopefully it could
be long enough till that doesn't fill
with fluid and you can't get it in at
all and that's why people die but the
hope is is that we can block it from
getting that leakiness in the lung oh
gosh so you wait I'm gonna get back now
I just want to talk about sleep you lie
on a device that it's under my mattress
measures your movements at night it
actually measures my heart rate in my
movie it tells me how much I am sleeping
how much sleep I get and I get a little
on my app I get to see it's a company
called Withings you know for 80 bucks
you could buy this little thing it goes
under your mattress and I start to see
you know when I'm stressed I sleep less
I get to see behaviors and it changes me
I'm one of those geeks that you know I
like to know my data and you don't take
anything to sleep
no glycine does that work at all no no
but if it's a placebo it would what how
I mean the placebo effect is it effect
right body's not used to taking one
amino acid and these things everything
you take has a ramification exercise
great for sleep yes but in the morning
during the morning well if you exercise
before you eat you can actually lose
more weight look a secret okay some
people do that so anytime exercise great
for sleep obviously getting away from
blue light 3-4 hours before you go to
bed is critical unless you're watching
this podcast in which case it's fine yes
well you can actually set your iPhone
your iPad to block out those colors yes
I do it in grayscale mode and then yes
turn off the blue light but there's
actually really cute blue light glasses
now I think we're going to start making
them for the podcast the blue light
glasses that how you gonna get them to
people that out
when you meet and sell them oh selling
it what are them I think you're making
them for oh yeah just like my arts and
crafts no I'm gonna sell them out like
as merge can I ask you just in terms of
like some other health things that I
think are important I'm just gonna ask
it and you're gonna probably scoff cell
phones causing cancer not causing cancer
can I put my laptop on my uterus so it's
an amazing story so what happened was
the World Health Organization this
remarkable group that's given us all the
great Kovan 19 issued a statement that
cell phone cause cancer and the reason
they did is they did a survey of people
with brain cancer and they said how much
cell phone did you use and they asked
the spouse so the person with brain
cancer used three times as much as the
spouse the answer so therefore they said
there must be an association so they
issue this so I did a very clever thing
as I went to the people who actually
most people bring cancer or died and
went to their spouse I can I see your
cell phone bill we chose 200 of them and
we looked and it turned out it was
exactly the same usage so human
perception is to blame something so I
went before Congress and we actually
testified and I said listen if cell
phone calls come brain cancer there must
be a big increase from 1970 till today
because nobody had a cell phone that
have you anybody looked at the data they
all looked around the room nobody ever
did I showed them the data it's a
totally flat line it hasn't changed at
all so it's very hard to prove a
negative yeah there's no data that cell
phone brain cancer you would think right
handers you hold your phone to the right
side of your head right more brain
cancer on the right head there's not so
there's no data that it does cause
cancer but it's impossible to prove a
negative so no cell phones there's no
data at all that they do cause brain
cancer or airplanes being on our
airplane does expose you to some
radiation yeah and that's real and so
but you'll covet flight attendants and
pilots don't have more cancer than yeah
right right so from that we can assume
that there's not a dramatic increase in
risk
what about microwaves my grave don't
affected it all no much just excite
water you can get in a microwave I had a
microwave for like three years
listen you can have a microwave now an
ibuprofen look what I've done in your
life all right Benson there's a lot
going on the most important thing right
now is what are
health isn't it not our mental health
that ship has sailed but our physical
health which is why I recommend thrive
high-quality organic and non-gmo
groceries delivered to your door because
who's ever gonna go to a store again
that's canceled stores or public spaces
are canceled delivered to your door for
a lot less than you're paying now and
it's also gonna help out some families
in need that's what I'm doing since I
discovered thrive market as a proud
thrive market member I get the products
I love and paid membership provides a
free one for someone in need also so
your karma is on point what I like is
that this place anything you order from
here is gonna be fine you'd have to like
read the labels you don't have to like
exhaust yourself trying to like figure
out what's good and bad in the grocery
store they've done that already they've
done the legwork you answer a few
questions you're good to go I know what
is my diet Benton we don't do dairy
because mommy's skin is broken and so we
have a no dairy
we have no gluten we have keto remember
the keto pizza you ordered from here and
you made it for me and put vegan as a
member I'm saving 25 to 50% off
traditional retail prices and they're
carbon neutral shipping that's so cool
is free on orders over $49 they're also
going to match donations to their kovat
19 Relief Fund dollar for dollar that's
incredible the hog market is working
24/7 to make sure members are getting
their groceries delivered as fast as
possible so we don't all starve to death
in quarantine you can learn more about
their commitments to customers and
membership matching on their website to
try thrive market and become a member
risk free go to thrive Martin comm /
good for you join today and you'll get
up to $20 in shopping credit towards
your first order I got distracted cuz
you know how Bilborough on his podcast
he goes the first week is free and I
really tried to not do it and I couldn't
help myself
thrive thr I ve market.com
/ good for you to start your risk free
chef's and get up to $20 first twerps
Benton you're the one with speech
impediment how come did I catch it from
you is it contagious it's not like Kobe
is it this is like I work and you cough
in my face and I caught your speech
impediment thrive market.com / good for
you thank you guys for making my life a
little simple during this nightmare
dumpster fire of a time at least I'll
have to worry about ingredients in my
food
hey Benton have you always wanted to
learn it have you always wanted to learn
a new language yeah what do you want to
learn and I would like to learn Mandarin
why the two places with the highest with
the two place of the highest governorate
what is this you want to go visit that I
bet flights are cheap I would love to
learn Mandarin I would love to learn
Italian as well but I definitely want to
learn Spanish oh yeah of course
so are you gonna get me Babel vamos
Babel is that my basically fluent right
Babel is designed to quickly get you
speaking your new language within weeks
with daily 10 to 15 minute sessions see
this is it the problem is I get so bored
and I get so distracted I can't I can't
sit after 15 minutes I tune out anyway
so this is perfect his babble teaches
real-life conversations you're not
learning words and phrases out of
context right you're learning through
interactive dialogues which they say
that's the fastest way to learn I
learned French for like two months
because I dated a French guy when I was
in college and when I look back I have
someone packing to do around it but the
main thing is that I picked up a lot of
French just by talking to him so babble
works cuz it's built around real life
how people actually communicate and what
they actually care about like you know
when you um I remember one time I took
French class and I learned all these
phrases and I was like zut alors all
vaad this go thank and then you actually
go to France and they're like no one
talks like that like oh that's what they
teach you there like discotheque like
that's not even the world we use so
items you're like learning like what the
way people talked in the 70s so this is
perfect because with their teaching
method it's been proven to be effective
across multiple studies you can choose
from 14 different languages this isn't
great if you want to fake your death
which I'm seriously thinking about this
is a great product for you you can learn
Spanish French Italian and German if you
want to become a spy this is your
product dude I'm telling you the speech
recognition technology helps you improve
your pronunciation and accent babble is
available as an app or online perfect so
your progress will be synced across all
devices this is pretty genius right now
babble is offering our listeners three
months free with a purchase of three
month put a subscription with the promo
code good for you go to babble com use
promo code good for you on your three
month subscription learn a language grow
your brain have something else to add to
your dating profile speak Spanish see
you but you're able to put that in your
dating profile you're gonna vibrate
better people I'm telling you this helps
you in so many ways go to babble comm
use the promo code good for you oh my
god you can put on your resume this is
like this is a no-brainer free three
shoot your three month subscription the
word free and see when I start reading
the ads that's when things fall off the
wagon babble be a BB al.com promo code
good for you let me see if I can say
that in French ball dole see I know a
little French
what about peptides injectable peptides
why are you injecting pain what are they
supposed to do because I'm a woman in
Hollywood who's 37 I don't want to play
mom roles so all a peptide is is it's
basically a segment of amino acids a
part of a protein yeah so injecting that
in you transiently will bring in fluid
so you can look fuller and that's what
it does it can take away wrinkles and
make you look fuller but it doesn't help
you at all ah way to bring in fluid
they're safer and better ways to do it I
wouldn't inject peptides what's the
safer way to do it just drink water but
soft drink matter feels like coconut
water or organic sport drink right
because water distributes throughout
your whole body you look puffy but this
stays inside your blood vessels right
because it has electrolytes in it and so
much healthier to do that gosh I've been
doing everything wrong and then it
should be will be worried about drinking
out of plastic water bottles that have
been in the Sun in our car certainly
plastic water bugs aren't great mhm so
if you don't have to I probably wouldn't
drinking it from it once in a while is
not gonna harm you dramatically but
they're not great for the environment
certainly how do you feel things are
gonna change in terms of the way this
virus spread the eating of you know bats
and exotic animals you think it's going
to change the way we look at what we eat
so historically almost all viral
outbreaks throughout history came from
livestock so they came from animals that
we kept right when you know when the
white man came to America we killed most
of the Indians by giving them viruses
right they didn't give us any because
they didn't have pets Wow I didn't ever
says they didn't have cows they didn't
have livestock we did now because we've
encroached upon the environment we're
getting viruses for the first time from
wild animals this is new wild animals
and so yes our relationship with nature
has to change yeah and we have to be
very aware of it and we have to actually
think forward how to protect ourselves
and hopefully we'll do that so what it's
going to mean is that science is going
to be able to think what could happen
not what is happening mm-hm and we have
the technology we have the ability to
really keep ourselves healthy as a
planet we just have to be able to use it
and we need the resources to do it I
think that will happen now and then do
is it still the case that in more
polluted areas kovat effects were worse
because of smog and pollution hell I
mean as many other things in more
polluted areas there was more dense
population there were classically poor
populations there less health care there
are a lot of reasons was very hard to
get reduction is there right
so certainly pollution isn't great right
but you can live in New York City and
people can live a long normal healthy
life and living in New York City which
is a pretty polluted place compared to
living in the middle of the country so
it's hard to get that reductionists and
this caused this mmm certainly there are
those associations but a lot of things
we're going on in those areas people
walk less people exercising all of
things are we ever gonna be able to vape
again vaping was scary right yeah
problem is is that you couldn't get your
nicotine into your lungs might of being
on something so a very clever pharmacist
in China said hey listen if I use
polyethylene glycol or some you know a
you know basically derivative of
antifreeze
I could put tobacco there and then it
would carry nicotine I mean nicotine on
it could carry nicotine or THC into the
lung yeah the problem is those things
stayed there and they started to coat
our lungs and so it means over time you
don't get oxygen diffusion you can never
be an athlete you can't really exercise
and it can cause significant problems as
we saw in that generation then you saw
lots of nicotine at AC going to the
brain at once and that wasn't good
either and what's causing problems I
mean literally wasn't smart we thought
vaping was like healthier than smoking
certainly smoking ain't good either
yeah but vaping yes this was a quick fix
that we never studied and we just did
and we put it inside our body and that
wasn't smart this is wild
I'm obsessed with your book and I'm says
that that you bring up dogs and my dogs
are healthy for humans and I always
think dogs are medicine not only because
the neuro chemicals that you admit you
right serotonin actually but also the
routine that dogs help you establish
it's the coolest right I think you don't
stay out too late cuz you gotta walk
your dog yeah you eat your dog you know
your dog will get pissed to you if you
need a half-hour late from yeah so you
regular mealtimes and it's that
unconditional love my dog doesn't care
what happened to me yes and now we have
to they're so excited to see us it is
the great we got so lucky in that
beginning a genuine before all of this
mm-hmm we got a puppy mmm not knowing
and Emmas and this puppy thinks I have
the coolest family in the world they're
always home they're always around you
have no idea what the real world is like
this puppy and if I say this puppy
doesn't get to meet other dogs or other
people because it's always home hmm
isn't it also true science that if you
are in a bad mood and you like just
force yourself to smile you're already
gonna be in a better mood it mean just
try it you smile your body feels
differently yes no I do it like when
everything when I'm exercising and I'm
struggling I will smile and then I will
I feel myself get stronger
it made it does I mean it's
pretty amazing you know you have about
85 muscles in the face and so the
greatest actors in the world can
probably control 25 of them and do a
fake smile right you and I well your
actor but if I try to do a fake smile I
could probably control ten of them and
so the human brain is amazing I can know
when a smile is real or not yes that is
so fascinating that cues we see are just
amazing in that regard well I am gonna
show you my robot after we talk and I
have this robot that looks exactly like
me and I got super fascinated by
pathogen avoidance about the way when
you see like a scarecrow or a doll or a
clown or something you got the way
humans recoil just in something that
looks human but doesn't move like a
human the way we're able to serve the
uncanny valley of it all the fact that
we are just so wired to be completely
disgusted by dolls or mannequins and
creeped out by it isn't that our way of
not procreating with something that's
dead oh yeah no I mean there's there's
all these amazing cues that are within
us I saw your robot on Netflix sorry
about that very cute sorry about the
nightmares thank you she has a broader
range of emotions in me at this point I
might have to send her on the road if
this code continues to do my stuff but
I'm so fascinated by that and then can I
just everyone that listens to Spock has
knows how obsessed I am with epigenetic
imprinting is this this is real true
science what is true joy just the fact
that we ever heard of the word The
Weeknd epigenetics we could what does it
mean how dare you throw me under the bus
that we can inherent traumas and fears
from generations before us irrational
fears so you know what we know about
epigenetics is that you have DNA three
billion letters and then there are sugar
groups on top of it that are in response
to things that happen to you mm-hmm
so if your parents smoked right in utero
that can affect how some of your DNA was
passed and so that's what we call
epigenetics it's passed from generation
to generation right and our behavior
matters and we never knew why certain
behaviors can be passed and this is the
reason we can't understand it yet right
so I can't look at your DNA and say what
you will pass to a little boy or a
little girl you hate but alcoholism we
just don't know what it means yet or how
to manage it or control it and in terms
of like
nature versus nurture like I have a lot
of addiction in my family and I'm always
fascinated you know something we say in
the 12-step program is that genetics
loads the gun environment pulls the
trigger but not just sound good or is
that true you know you are the first
experiment you were an experiment of
your parents right right so you know in
general genetics is a portion so there
was an amazing study Google bought the
genetic database of ancestry.com yeah
and they started to say what percent of
longevity is genetic and the numbers
amount four percent so ninety-six
percent is your behavior but the amazing
part is I can know how long someone will
live by looking how long their spouses
mother lives because you classic you
marry people they're similar to you Wow
someone's behavior is very similar to
their parents so that tells me more than
looking at your DNA Wow
and so it's an amazing to me that's a
powerful statement it because it's
empowering you're in charge of your own
destiny your DNA is a portion of your
destiny but it's a relatively small
portion because your genetics for
inheriting you know a compulsive
behavior or addictive behavior and you'd
hear from both parents and they got
together and that's a novel mix so I
don't know what it will be for you but
you're in charge of you mm-hmm and it
really is powerful it's not predestined
but it's not deterministic I'm gonna
take a real real hard pivot here am I
gonna of my breasts my breasts plants
gonna kill me there's no data that
there's any negative effect to it really
yeah
well you're with I think mine got
recalled I think I might have to get new
ones there like a like a child's toy at
this or like arugula it's just mine went
bad I did mine like three years ago oh
they're they're fine they're fine I'm in
I'm out of the woods yeah I'm good on
this no I mean you're still gonna have a
breast exam you're still gonna have you
know mammogram mm-hmm because that's
critically important yeah implants
themselves aren't gonna cause a problem
and then my father when he passed there
was a little bit of a conversation about
antibiotic resistance he passed before I
was really able to understand what
happened is because they kept saying we
can't give him any more antibiotics his
little sort of stopped working and
there was conversation about it being in
meat is that real well antibiotic
resistance is the bacteria it's not you
okay so you can't inherit that right so
the bacteria over time remember where do
we get antibiotics from we got it from
bacteria right so bacteria use it to
kill other bacteria right right the
penicillin comes from mold so we
basically got it also gross you think
about it
it is one of the most elegant and
amazing we've ever done science and
you're calling it like mold basically
just like solved our problems as humans
you know the turn of the century we
never had a cut on your leg did one of
the great experiments done was there
were five people in each arm
yeah half they left it open to the air
and half they took a piece of bread and
they dipped it in water and that healed
the wound twice as fast and literally it
changed everything it's crazy because
right the bread may mold the mold maybe
penicillin and it spun germ theory and
all of a sudden we had a new way
remember you and I have crazy
inflammatory systems yeah to fight off
infectious disease the good is is we
could temper that down with a baby
aspirin or things like lipitor mm-hmm we
can live much longer yeah because we're
not we now have vaccines we have
antibiotics we have antivirals if we
temper that down we live longer because
that inflammation leads to heart disease
cancer and Alzheimer's is eating
antibiotics so much in me gonna cause a
problem you know it's certainly not good
and you know I think that you know you
need to know what you eat right so
there's plenty of meat that is
antibiotic for you know I would focus in
that direction yeah I do think it's an
issue that we use them a lot especially
in you know animals and we can get
antibiotic resistance and all of that
that's not a good thing mm-hmm but
certainly in getting organic milk you
know getting you know grass-fed beef
it's a very healthy way to eat I love
what you say I was in your book but I
also was watching a talk of you saying
shop the perimeter of a grocery store
and know your grocery yeah yes camera
her what came in fresh today yeah you
know what's in season you know fruits
and vegetables they start to great as
soon as they're picks they want to put
the nutrients back in the soil Mary it's
right so get what was picked recently or
flash-frozen
don't get something shipped him from
another country has been sitting on a
boat for a week right Victor
right and then I remember this is before
I you know was able to text you I
remember I was really struggling with
what to eat and a doctor said to me the
neuro chemicals in the stress you're
admitting about it is so much worse than
just eating the thing because when I go
on the road I'm like in an airport at
night it's all fast-food and she's like
the stress that you're emitting about
what to eat is worse for you than just
eating the bad thing that one time and
it's not that you know there's no food
that's horrible and there's no food
that's perfect mm-hmm everything falls
in the middle and I think that's what's
good I mean is that we can all you know
every once and while we all do
everything I love my french fries I love
my pizza
I mean it's having moderation that's the
key Mediterranean diet is by far and
away the healthiest diet Wow right
protein if added every meals with some
carbs I mean that's it but are we now
how to cook with olive oil sure you can
cook really just not to high temperature
okay and we can't burn our toast I saw
you talking about this course you can
bring over just find it burn your toast
that was so misguided right the
recommendations are that it was crazy
and no tuna well not too much tuna yeah
I mean everybody loves to go to Nobu
right just not too much of it if I wanna
if I'm gonna have a my eggs are frozen
in Redondo Beach if I want to have a
baby via IVF I shouldn't eat a lot it
was like frozen it why did you put them
in Redondo Beach huh well that's where
they freeze them I don't know that's
where they are that's where they're
stored my doctor's I guess like the
storage unit is gonna you know keep them
in your office if that's okay we don't
store eggs at the present time but maybe
one day last couple things
did you see the gyms where people were
working out in like plastic tarps are we
in idiocracy it's like the you know you
see the gym and the you know there's the
escalator you go to the gym there's a
gym on Sunset called crunch and you had
to walk up a flight of stairs nothing
nevermind I'm gonna go to you coccyx I
don't want to climb a flight of stairs
to work out just even the notion we have
to go somewhere to workouts crazy
so that's on it so when is it
you're going to a movie listen I've
loved seeing him at home mm-hmm it's fun
okay I'll just come to your husband you
know I'm one of those people that I
never loved movie theater yeah I love
see him in a home it's great I love
seeing with friends I just saw the king
of Staten Island it was great so guys
yeah and it's funny you know unfortunate
not that many movies are coming out now
that's the negative much powder mm-hmm
good ones and when are you going to a
comedy show next whenever your next one
is will be when you tell me to go this
is a very contingent on you you know yes
because I'm in the first quarter next
year there will be comedy shows back
there maybe sooner no question we've
little bit right yeah we book shows in a
salt lake city Alabama
Tempe like at half capacity you know as
long as they're doing it right five
homes and people have to wear masks yes
Wow it's not that big a deal
mm-hmm it's not that big a deal there's
this new thing called Netflix we my
specials and now streaming but um but
then big venues you don't think till
next year concerts Coachella it's not
gonna be for a while
I mean till we really have a vaccine
implemented it doesn't make sense it's
just too many people together and then
they lose inhibitions people drink
alcohol they lose inhibitions and they
do the wrong thing and then it's not the
young people I'm worried I worry about
when they go home right right and people
that live with their parents and
grandparents and his or their friend
who's gonna chemotherapy they can kill
people we just don't want that and then
when we get the vaccine for this this is
like the when people say the new normal
that drives me nuts about like this is
something we're gonna be dealing with
just as humans for the rest of time yeah
but we're gonna be better dealing right
this crisis will bring in a new I keep
thinking you ever see the Portlandia
yeah they wanted to go to the concert
and they sent a drone you know they
bought their own drone and they spent
all this money and they're all watching
it and then as soon as the consciousness
but he just takes a baseball bat and
hits their drone and they lost the
concert
do you hate watching medical shows does
it drive you nuts sometimes times
they're not most of them that well done
very frustrating right I'm gonna strive
you insane and then what do you make
about these like movies like contagion
and I mean it's great yeah you know when
I was a kid I read the Michael Crichton
books and it changed my life
yeah excited about science yeah
yeah yeah I made a movie about Neurology
it's called the female brain and I had a
couple like neurologists randomly
imprisoning yes the movie of that but we
did yes
she's fantastic she's fantastic I went
up and I sat with her in Sausalito
I guess I'm allowed to say where she
lived right and and her dress I know
exactly 904 - and we like spent the day
together and she said something that
really changed my life where I was like
okay just what can you tell me to change
my life about you know neurology men's
brains women's brains and she just goes
your boyfriend is not your girlfriend
like just yeah you know just keep the
conversation shorter don't you know talk
to them about your friend's wedding for
two hours don't expect them to get
dopamine from gossip the way she's just
about the male brain - yes yes yeah so I
made that movie and and I had to get
really vague because it's I also realize
like it's so weird to think that you
know I guess this is why they called
medicine a practice and not like the
championship like it's your social
learning stuff of the Champions yeah
this is me not perfect like you know and
I remember I dated an anesthesiologist
once who said the medicine we're doing
the best we can with the information we
have get a little this last week just
last week the first paper was ever
published to show how anesthesia works
so we've been using anesthesia for two
hundred years it's ether and we didn't
know how it worked they finally figured
it out last they take you to the brink
of death and back but we had no idea how
it worked in the brain so there's so
much in what we do which is serendipity
it's observation is real data yes don't
know why or how and it's amazing to me
that you know that piece was the most
elegant paper in the world but we had no
idea how it works and so much we don't
know so I remember when we were working
on the graphics for that movie like the
part of the brain that's received Allah
that's responsible for you know emitting
you know adrenaline she's like just make
it a big circle because we're not sure
exactly in there with it's this organ
that you know it controls us we have no
idea really how it works at all we don't
have the brain work you know like we
look back one of my favorite things is
when you know you're getting older
because you go to the doctor and there's
new technology that you're like you know
when remember when they just like knock
on your knee with a little mini hammer
he'll do
with that everybody would do that to me
recently I need to get a new doctor but
every when you go in and you know
there's like new stuff like I went got a
mammogram and it there was this crazy
machine and stuff like that and it's
what in 20 years are we gonna look back
and be like god that was so archaic I
was like the leeches so number one of
2020 in the next couple years the notion
that you go to your doctor's office and
they collect data right they draw your
blood they do whatever they call you if
you go there that makes no sense yeah so
we're all gonna have a device at home
where we prick our finger and there were
mail the CD we put the CD in a runs all
our tests and one Elizabeth Holmes made
there will be one to actually works yeah
Barbie oven and it's gonna be pretty
soon and so you actually go to your
doctor have a real conversation which
will be really powerful imaging a
mammogram I mean that's from Marie Curie
shooting x-rays through tissue right
energy through tissue that itself can
cause cancer in problems and it's very
poor resolution we're gonna have to be
much better over time
about imaging you know the Navy can look
a mile away and know what kind of fish
is there we can't look inside a human
breast without squishing and passing
x-rays through it it's never a
comforting when you're getting an x-ray
or something and the person doing it
sprints out of the room like a hundred
miles an hour it like takes cover so
those technologies will be
revolutionized part of it is you know
the transition to 5g so 5g you know it's
this amazing bandwidth for data which by
the way is safer than others because
it's very can't penetrate very well
humans safer than others but what it
does is allows you to have technologies
without computing and all of this stuff
it just collects the data and all of the
computers we call it the edge so it can
then collect it and then process it far
away where it's really expensive so the
cost will come down dramatically we'll
be able to you know take data all over
the place go to your doctor and a two
o'clock he or she checking your blood
pressure makes no sense you want to go
in with weeks of data right your
movement data with more data error goes
away that's gonna happen that's the new
transition you're Steve Jobs
we would say with him he was so pissed
off that they would you know he had a
transplant I mean of his liver I don't
have to prick his finger every hour to
check his sugar and he thought that was
barbaric so he bought up all the
intellectual property
to measure things through the skin so
you're gonna be able to measure insulin
look of course all the things through
the skin and you're gonna notice listen
when I need Wonderbread look what
happens to my sugar I'm not gonna be
Wonder Bread and let me ask you cuz I'm
working on the TV show version of super
sad true love story which is a dystopian
satire of the future but all that's not
gonna be like publi like that's gonna be
the next conversation as the privacy of
is that just gonna be uploaded to a
database and sold or insurance companies
when you bought this house your bank
although you may be so wealthy its need
incredibly they asked you to give you
every bit of your financial data and you
did without blinking right everything
you had you gave it to your bank if I
say to you listen I just want to be able
to use your healthcare data in an
anonymized protective way to help others
you go no freakin way that's my health
care data we view healthcare data
different than everything else sure why
fascinating pedestal but if we all gave
our data again in a privacy protective
way to one collected database we can
actually solve problems so if I if I can
use that data to help others I can solve
many the healthcare problems we have
there's such a psychological thing
around data that's so fascinating like
when people are like they don't want to
do 23andme they're like I don't want
anyone on my date I'm like they're
finding serial killers like in a choice
between having serial killers off the
street and giving up their data they'd
rather serial killers be roaming the
streets yes I mean we view health care
very differently it's a problem and also
just in general like all of the you know
privacy might you have to take you have
to give your phone number in order to do
it I'm like I remember when there used
to be a book full of everyone's numbers
and like a home addresses and they would
just throw it on your porch you know
this paranoia around data I feel like is
is is that something that's people have
taken advantage of it yeah yeah you know
we don't trust companies anymore there's
no moral standards there no ethical
standards anymore and what we need to do
is we need to do that hmm and it's
difficult you know their technology is
changing so quickly in our country the
problem is is that our rules aren't
changing as quickly you know when
Angelina Jolie announced that she had
the mutant G for breast cancer your time
rock right Rep rocket they asked me to
write the companion piece and I said
when is it do they go an hour I wrote
about that in the 90s there was
team that was given 26 million dollars
and they identified the gene and then
they gave it to a company the company
went bankrupt and another company bought
the assets and sold the tests for $6,000
so what I wrote about was how dare a
company charged a woman a six thousand
dollar ransom to look at her own DNA
it's predatory practice and it's
monopolistic its criminal so you know
company I'm really mad threatened
lawsuits and what do you know four
months later the Supreme Court announced
you can't patent a gene anymore in our
country so now that test is 60 bucks so
one of the Supreme Court justices
actually called me up and goes aren't
you proud of us we read your piece and
we actually made it so you can't patent
a gene I go yes but it took you 12 years
to do it and in that 12 years a hundred
and fifty thousand women lost their life
because they couldn't afford to actually
pay the ransom to look at their own DNA
and can I also just add because I was
I've been googling you hard that the way
they've found the bracha gene was from
Mormon Church that's pretty well that is
fascinating
although murmurs want to be buried in
the church and they couldn't fit so they
took a piece of them their hair and
their history and it was in the church
so we DNA going back a hundred years and
we can actually go and in these large
family be able to identify the gene
there were just tons of hair samples
there just for you to to go back and do
that and you know there wasn't they
didn't care about the privacy per se was
all privacy protected nobody knew
anybody's names but now all those
databases have gone away nobody wants
you to do DNA betas you can figure out
you know and my cousin may be a serial
killer as you alluded to and yeah they
don't want to do it but yeah it was
amazing and it saved a lot of people's
lives and will continue to do so so
we're not we're not doing comedy this
year huh no Yuk Yuk's isn't comedy the
best medicine though laughter is the
best I know you're the doctor here but
entertainment is amazing I mean and you
know one of them listen I moved to LA
and everyone made fun of me right on the
East Coast how dare you it's not a
serious city I went I was in Amsterdam
and I was at a dinner and I guy next me
they put me next to this guy with one of
those twisty mustaches taking my son
when I went to Anne Frank House and how
meaningful was he looked at me goes I
knew Han okay what do you mean he goes I
live four houses down from her I hid
during the war and survived she didn't
he told me about growing up with Anne
Frank well and he took
me to her house and at night and we're
in her room he goes what do you notice
about this room I don't know they just
cut off some magazine he goes that's
Hollywood magazines he goes the world
lives through the entertainment that's
created in your city your city gives
more joy to the world than any other
place you don't realize that most of the
world has no entertainment and this city
Los Angeles creates it for the world
and it was what Muhammad was beautiful
advertisement for the city I had ever
seen that's really touching and you know
I you know in writers rooms and stuff
were always like oh we're not curing
cancer and like oh we're not rocket
scientists and stuff both my parents had
strokes in the same year and I was in
the ICU for like a year straight
basically and it was like you know
obviously heartbreaking I don't have to
tell you and I'm walking through in
every single room is Seinfeld and
everyone loves Raymond and sick and
they're just sitting there you know like
we're worried anesthesiologists in a way
you know like we that's what we do but
it's also in our nature to self
deprecated to hate ourselves that's why
we get funny in the first place but
Anderson we try to tell jokes our
business I've got three and that they're
my good jokes I try to go to them my
patients have to laugh I would go in
everything I was having something in my
chest that you probably are gonna tell
me isn't even real called Costco
chondrite it's real it's real I had like
plurals inflammation in cartilage yeah
it's uh and and I went in and so I had a
Rheumatologist and I had to go in you
know like a couple times a year and I go
and and I be like so how's it he's like
just kidding
this wild bedside manner all right
they're two boys outside an operating
room there's a ten and an eleven
year-old okay so the ten year old says
he'll ever what are you here for he goes
I'm here on my tonsils out because it's
not bad I had it last year get to sail
from school you get ice cream because
what are you here for you guys are here
to have a circumcision yeah it's
horrible how do I when I was first born
and I couldn't walk for a year straight
doctor it's the only kind of comedy that
can't get cancelled at this point you
might
be the biggest comedian in comedy right
now honestly if you wanted to be there's
none left you know I was privileged to
take care of Merv Griffin ah I love to I
mean literally loved him you know toward
the end of his life he was in the
hospital and literally you know I was
there doing my rounds and seeing him and
he's like everyone out of the room I got
to talk to agus because I got to tell
something very important and so I watch
everybody leaves the room and I go I'm
ready for the meaning of life and I'm
looking Eileen David he goes there's a
16 year old boy he went to a pharmacy to
buy condoms for the first time and I go
yeah and he goes he waited for those
nobody in the store finally everybody
left and he goes and he puts him on the
counter and the pharmacist looks at him
and goes it's two forty-nine plus tax
and the kid goes you have to use tax
okay because everybody else can come
back in and how is Merv's meaning of
life to me a last last thing is taking
him old fillings give you mercury
poisoning there certainly was some
mercury in old fillings and so you know
taking them out means drilling and yeah
you can get a transient increase in
mercury it's not the same kind of
mercury that causes very where's mercury
come from by the way the planet Mercury
that's a true fact oh I didn't know had
you not heard that yet no did you not
get that data I'll send it to you later
I'll send it so it's an impurity and
coal yes you burn coal it goes into the
atmosphere right and that it's elemental
mercury the same thing in your feelings
that doesn't really are because that's
what goes into the water that absorbs
into the bag and then Bert bacteria
convert to methyl mercury and the first
hundred feet of water sunlight degrades
bacteria so it's only deep fish in his
big fish and so if sunlight could
engrave methyl mercury
why can't we figure out ways of doing it
and so you know there was a fish market
in Seattle that used to have a slight
swabby tell you how much mercury is in
the fish all of a sudden the fish market
you know everybody hated it because of
the word these fish that weren't eaten
and they stopped doing it mm-hmm but in
America you know about 12 to 15 percent
of kids that are born or from a mother
that has a mercury level can affect
brain development of the child as
predominately wealthy women because
that's a great go to sushi yeah and it's
kind of while we have to be really aware
of it
salmon is better and great right you
know literally a hundred serving
salmon is equivalent to one serving a
swordfish whoa so what a mercury basis 3
102 9 9 9 3 2 2 and I will text back
jokes I've only got one more left can we
have it are you gonna save it I'm gonna
save that one I seriously do think why
can't you shoot I mean you can do it
here you can shoot answers to some of
these questions and send it out in video
or put it you know on a website or
something because no offense to all you
texting I'm glad but to not be able to
share like share it with everyone you
could send a video back to your whole
database based on that noise sure I'm
getting used to these things I know and
doing it and it's you know it's I mean
they're so powerful yeah amazing listen
I get feedback I know when I go on TV
and talk on the news and something I can
go on Twitter I know what people
understand what they didn't what they
liked what they didn't it's a feedback
makes me better yeah but I also think
that the way that you behave one-on-one
with someone is different than the way
you're gonna behave publicly like a lot
of people might not want to make a
comment and get involved or like you
know for me the reason I want to do
these podcasts is to go like I'm gonna
ask all the dumb questions that people
are too embarrassed to like not know the
answer to you know cuz I think most of
the time I don't ask questions because I
don't want people to think I don't know
and then you never know anything and
then you just get to stay an idiot right
although a lot of people are doing then
is it difficult ya notice we need to we
need to have more conversation and we
need to have things like this which is
discourse about ideas but you also we
don't have access to doctors like we
don't have access like this to you know
people like you you know early on in my
career you know there was a remarkable
mentor I have Mehcad who came to me and
said party role as education and I was
at sloan-kettering I was in New York I
was a you know serious scientist and I
go I don't give he goes yes you do and
he scheduled 200 talks in a year for me
Wow
cuz I wasn't a good public speaker and
he made me learn how to speak you're
such a good public speaker every day at
5 o'clock I'd have to show up somewhere
give a talk he forced me to this might
make me start a podcast a really amazing
guy Andy Grove he was the CEO of Intel
Holocaust survivor out of the microchip
and you know he didn't ask he just did
it and it really changed me and realized
that we have to educate ya because I
think especially like such smart people
like it's like you know to now you need
to be able to disseminate
information like you have it all but we
you know dumb people like me need to be
able to understand it and then repeat it
to someone else right and then you need
to go and go to Redondo Beach and tell
these stories to your eggs I'm such a
deadbeat mom I haven't visited them in
so long
should I have a kid right now I get that
question a lot and you know yes it is
healthy too oh that's I don't know your
personal right
there's no reason we're in Corbin 19 you
can't get pregnant you can't have a
child mm-hmm
we're not like stressing out the medical
system it's not canonical and I mean
what's amazing is we kids are a sporadic
and there's very little kid to kid
spread and kid to adult spread rights
and we don't know why but that data are
real but yes it is totally fine to have
a child in today's world if your kid is
eight what comfort level are you with
them going back to school in the fall
what do you want to look like I just
want this school to be aware and so you
know we'll see what the data are and
it's going to vary by location so in
certain locations we're not gonna have
to do much other locations where there's
a higher incidence or a higher
positivity we're gonna do a little bit
more and maybe you have to wear masks
and other things right it really is
gonna depend on where in the country you
are and what is the data I'd rather it
be data-driven right right right then
blanket rather than just blanket cuz
blanket makes no sense mm-hmm so think
critically we have to think critically
is what you're saying we can't make
giant generalization and I think that's
sometimes hard it's a lot easier to all
do the same thing three 102 9 9 9 3 2 -
I
Taylor is in the room with me she knows
that like a month ago I was like I can't
read news anymore CNN saying something
different than the Atlantic that's
different than Fox like I just was like
getting so overwhelmed and with what's
going on in the news now lots of things
are eclipsing Co vid so it's not like
all the front page every right now I
feel like I have to seek it out I feel
like it's changing every day this is
truly the only way I'm getting my news
are just text from him that I imagine
you're texting me that it's just me
that's just my fantasy but it goes to
all of you guys 3 102 9 9 9 3 2 2 it
also makes you healthier saves you the
stress of going to a new site and then
seeing all the other horrific things
that are going on in the world which is
just a giant like adrenaline and
cortisol spike putting you in
fight-or-flight mode so this to me is
the same as healthiest way to get news
about being sane and healthy so I'm so
grateful that you're doing this not
enough doctors are and and it's so hard
to get news responsibly now and to even
be able to trust any in the news that we
get you know it's a weird time in the
world it's a really weird time in the
world because it's like even the most
well-meaning people on the planet you
can go find news to justify the
misinformation you already have you know
find something I people will go I don't
believe you have to do this then they'll
just find an article that proves them
right wait listen
everything looks equal in the internet
it's all black and white and so there's
a lot of noise out there mm-hmm it's
really hard to get through that noise
the fact that television news now opens
like an action movie like a terminate
the music the flag like it's like to me
it's more about entertainment driven and
and you know media is in trouble right
now they are losing a lot of money they
have vested interest in getting our
eyeballs and getting us to click on
stuff so I think to me this is a way
that I feel safe of getting news I don't
feel like I'm being played or used or
lied so that they can get ad revenue so
thank you so much for doing this I'm
going to make you come back many many
times who would love to it's my
privilege and we can shoot a bunch of
stuff in here do you guys have any more
questions tailored to you what did I
miss
they're all selfish can I can you test
me right now so if people are everybody
in the room is in a mask except for the
speaker and everybody's distanced and
nobody's eating is that zero risk that's
fine whoa but if everybody's like eating
drinking laughing you know me so well
yeah then there's risk yeah
and so do that one out of doors right I
mean so you have to choose do I want to
figure out and go to a place as out of
doors well yeah behave a certain way
yeah I would be indoors we have to
behave a certain way because I think
this is important mostly because and
this is the last thing I will say is
that when we go so extreme the pendulum
swings hard and I feel like we go too
hard in the other direction if we're
just like going out in iterations that
make sense we're not gonna just like
snap and be like screw it I'm going to
sandals and I'm gonna do like we don't
explain things mm-hmm this second inning
is really hard because we don't know the
rules and you know our government
doesn't know the rules our leaders don't
know the rules how are we supposed to
use real makes it really difficult and
so we have to we have to break through
that listen in two months we're gonna
look back and everyone will be wearing a
mask in two months it's guaranteed
what's gonna happen is because of the
cases continuing now and the desk will
go up we're gonna say oh my gosh we
realized we have to wear a mask and
we'll be doing that right but between
now and then there's gonna be a lot of
stress and this is just how things work
why do people say it's gonna get worse
in the fall the notion is two things one
is is that when the flu happens and the
common colds happen that we're gonna
everybody's gonna think it's covet et
cetera right and then in the fall we're
plastically indoors and so when people
are in a place where there's less
ventilation they're more together and
then when they're outside and it's cold
right constricts blood vessels you get
leakiness as you said yeah a node can
transmit virus so that's how you know
the summer you don't leak right you're
out of doors and there's much less virus
Wow well a lot of my friends met you in
some either work situations and just
said can you meet my doctor and just
forced you to be their doctor so I feel
like that's in the cards for us okay
thank you you're the greatest thing I
always end these are very very awkwardly
there's no elegance to the end of this
but thank you so much this is gonna help
so many people and hopefully we'll be
able to do comedy soon without killing
our audience and their family
oh and get short guide to our long life
that's a game changer game changer
[Music]
[Applause]